alors il cherche est connu pour ses
coups de gueule ses coups de tête et
coups de coeur 1 c'est bien tu à alger
de faire une interview dernier coup tu
mens jamais eu celle là voilà un dernier
coup de gueule justement face à celui
des femmes il faut maintenant d'asie bon
j'ai pas répondre tout le temps à ta
place mais qu'est ce que tu veux je te
dis ton dernier coup de gueule dans la
vie voilà bon n'ont rien à penser un bon
nom en profil bas profil bas ouais
volontaire ouais difficile dit
visiblement face aux derniers coups de
coeur les conditions de marges
ouais dans les coupes points
il ya deux ans ouais ouais quand paquet
bahut à mike enfin c'est d'ailleurs
c'était pas volontaire
il s'est dit d'essayer de se raccrocher
et il a glissé une preuve la plate et
comme j'étais qu on a été déclarée match
nul dans la suivre
et comme avec le torchon c'est vachement
bien il y avait un berger allemand dans
les cieux au dernier coup de foudre des
coups de foudre
ouais ma fille dernier coup de rouge il
ya 14 mois à 14 mois à la flotte
ouais tu as maigri assad va bien bien
sida et la coupe de cheveux non mais
c'est vrai on serait pas en public la
dernier coup droit
bien et couvre un quelques jours ouais
c'est pas tous les jours non
combien de jours toujours à moussa c koi
trois fois par semaine ouais ben voilà
on est au courant comme dans les coups
de bluff que tu as fait à 38 ans je suis
tellement à dire après son contrôle et
là j'ai inscrit le nom des mecs que je
voulais dans mon film avant de leur
avoir demandé
ouais ouais du coup ils ont été obligés
avec ces tapis ministre c'est du bluff
pour toi ben alors il faut que c'était
son truc moi j'en sais rien moi ton
menaçant qui disent tout et c'est
caramba caramba tout ça non l'étape il
faut le laisser bosser
bon faudra bien arriver juste montrer un
truc sur tapis là il fait revenir si
c'est de l'info si c'est demain que m
regarde bien